and we interrupted Joe Pike to go to uh
Houston where uh Mick Lynch uh head of
the rmt is about to speak
can you turn around yeah so um the rnt
union today has decided to put a new
offer from Network rail
two members in an electronic referendum
with a recommendation to reject the
proposals from Network rail
and that referendum will close on Monday
December the 12th at noon
12 o'clock all the strike action that
we've got planned in December that's 13
14.
and so on we'll go ahead
um as planned as will the action in
January
um
but in addition to that further
we've also put further strike action
that will take place and all members
will be instructed not to book on from
1800 hours on December the 24th
until six o'clock in the morning on
December the 27th
this new phase of strike action
coincides with the wind down of the
passenger service from the national rail
network
and coincides with the commencement of
the engineering work scheduled for that
period
the overtime ban that had previously
been scheduled has been canceled on
network rail because of this new strike
action
in regards to the train operating
companies there's been no improved offer
from the rail delivery group and the
reason for that is because they have had
no mandate from the government the
government has not allowed any new offer
to be put to us today and there are the
meetings scheduled for tomorrow
planned in and we'll see if the rail
delivery group on behalf of the train
operating companies passenger Services
has got
a mandate to make us an offer so at the
minute we haven't got anything that's
acceptable to us
and we feel that we've been compelled to
take this action because of the
intransigence of the government
delivered to us by the employers
on the government's behalf
and that we've got no choice because
what we've been faced with is an
extremely detrimental offer it's a very
poor in relation to the pay elements
and our members simply aren't in the
position of the feedback that we've had
to accept the changes that the companies
have put on the table so the action will
go ahead there'll be more action during
the close down period on the railway
over Christmas
and all the other schedule action in the
new year is going ahead so that's an
unfortunate position
we remain open for discussion with the
companies they know what needs to be
done to get this
dispute progressed and get a settlement
going forward but at the moment we've
not got a means to a solution so our
members will have a say in network Rail
and they will all get a vote
uh individually they'll get all of the
details of the documentation and the
changes that the company wants to make
as well as the pay proposals they've put
up and they will decide whether they
want to settle it or not and we'll know
that on Monday the 12th of December so
that's where we are Mick if you're going
to the members why are you going to them
if your recommendation is to reject it
because there is a current of people
that say that we should have a vote we
should see you know what the members
feel about the proposals people have
said to us many times that you haven't
put this to members so there's an
improvement in the offer it has changed
from where it was
but the detrimental Parts the changes to
our members uh working lives in their
terms of conditions their work-life
balance
the safety regime that the company wants
to make the cut of inspections by 50 all
of that remains in place
so we're putting that to our members so
that they can have a they say but the
view of their Trade union is that these
measures are not acceptable and they
don't address the issues in the dispute
there isn't a sufficient pay offer
and there isn't uh a non-imposition of
changes if we were to accept these
changes as they've written now we would
be forcing them through on top of our
members wish to reject them so we'll
find out how strongly the members feel
about that if they want to accept it we
will abide by that
if they don't want to accept it we all
take the dispute forward does that
reflect that you feel under pressure
from some of your members though they're
giving up four days of pay over the
Christmas period they've clearly shown a
great deal of unity thus far but do you
feel a pressure to go to them we're not
feeling pressured from that there was a
strong feeling that we should just
reject it outright but we've got a
period of time now before the strike
action is scheduled to start another
week a little bit so we've got time to
put a referendum in there so that's what
we'll do and to be clear will those
strikes that again still involved the
network around and as well as the
training and stuff all of the strike
action remains in place but with network
rail there's additional strike action
during the Christmas close down which is
uh during the engineering more
experience with the offer a majority by
the road with review what is it about
that that you reject is it the payoff
pay off by that yes it's all of that but
it's a particular stigma yes there are
particular things so they know exactly
and we've told them across the table it
doesn't match the network rail offer
even we think that the network rail
offer is interior so they're playing
some kind of game with this staging that
we're seeing which I don't think is
appropriate in this dispute so it's far
inferior it's an offer that we rejected
in July as many of you all know when it
was put to network rail four percent
each year inflation at this time is 14.6
the retail price index
and it's it lasts over three years most
of our members have not had a pay deal
last year all the year before so over a
four year period it's only eight percent
and plus they want to close every
booking office in Britain they want us
to agree that there will be no guards on
trains going forward and there are a
whole host of other measures in detail
that we can't we can't go with at this
time what do you think the traveling
public would vote if you offered them
the chance given the Christmas
disruption you've you've had a
reasonably Fair win from quite a lot of
people thus far but Christmas next
weekend particularly that's a huge
moment for the economy and for people's
persons I'm sure that the traveling
public will be really disappointed and
irritated and angry what they what I
would ask them to remember and all those
businesses that have been in touch with
us the train operating companies will be
indemnified for all of their losses so
my members will lose money a lot of
money as you've set out
the public will lose the convenience of
having a trained service the businesses
around here and all around London and
all over the country will lose money
undoubtedly the only people that won't
lose money are the train operating
companies because the DFT and the
treasury will indemnify them against
their losses this is the most peculiar
and perverse industrial dispute you will
ever come across because the people that
I'm negotiating with don't suffer any
detriment whatsoever their Lifestyles
and their lavish salaries continue in
the Millions
and the train operating companies that
they represent don't have any loss of
Revenue or any loss of profit and in
fact they made profits all through the
pandemic and all through our strikes
they've made money and this government
is corrupting business in this country
it's punishing Brewers restaurateurs
entertainment industry in return for
their ideological dispute uh pursuit of
a dispute with the railways and the
trade unions and to set down a marker
against other public sector workers that
they've got to be impoverished for the
state of the economy that this
government drove us into and we've got a
new relatively new transport secretary
uh said to be making a more positive
contribution have you seen any evidence
of that practically in terms of this I
think the transport secretary is making
these decisions I've got to be very
Frank about that these decisions are
being made for a combination of the
treasury and I still believe that Grant
chaps is sticking his or into this
dispute because they knew that if they
put driver only operation back into this
debate it would never fly as a as a set
of proposals and I think that has come
directly from Grant chef
we've got a planned meeting tomorrow uh
hopefully in the morning we've got to
get that confirmed with the rail
delivery group Representatives but that
is predicated on the idea that the
government gives those people a mandate
in which the negotiate the framework and
at the moment they told me
No Such mandate has been delivered and
they knew when they put the proposals to
us on Sunday in a special session that
everything that they were put into US
was unacceptable so the people that are
delivering the message though is
unacceptable it's the people behind them
in the government in the DFT and the
treasury that are dictating the way this
dispute goes and the people that are
being held to Ransom are the travel in
public and this and the businesses that
will miss out during this period but we
cannot hold because what network rail
has told us
is that they will commence the changes
on December the 15th so in little over a
week's time they will commence the
changes including the job losses the
restructuring of all of our members
working lives whether we accept it or
not they will carry on and we will have
to put up with it so imposition is on
top of us that's why we have to escalate
the action and try to get a resolution
to this dispute